so if you haven't heard of dows that's
okay
basically it's a fancy term for a group
of people who come together with a
common interest and a shared bank
account
in some ways dows are similar to the
investment clubs that really got
popularized about a quarter century ago
with a group of women called the the
beardstown ladies and they started an
investment club and were picking stocks
and a lot of people believe that they
were really outperforming the market it
turned out that the way they were
calculating the investment returns was
wrong and they were actually
underperforming the market but the
concept of you know group of people
getting together to to invest and use
their kind of hive mind and collective
intelligence to invest is really the
same it just now does it digital you can
create a shared bank account very easily
with this technology one of the first
dows was called the dow started in 2016
and it was hack
and that put a real damper on daos for a
few years a couple years later there
were maybe about ten downs by 2020 there
were nearly 200 and then today there are
over four thousand some of the reasons
why dows have grown so much and they've
gotten more secure is the technology has
improved and the security has improved
you know back in 2016 from what i
understand there were maybe a handful of
people who did security on them to help
dao's really make sure they weren't
secure and got hacked now there's over
50 firms that do security auditing so
there's a lot more security there's
better infrastructure creating a digital
wallet sharing it with people allowing
people to vote on investment decisions
that technology has been built up a lot
more and then you have the growth of
crypto you know the price increases the
growth of nfts have all come together to
make daos much more popular i spoke with
aaron wright who is the co-founder and
ceo of tribute labs which is a new york
based company they're like a dow factory
they create dows
and they have a number of them and what
they do is they provide the technology
to help create downs they provide
administrative support around filing for
tax forms they moderate discussions for
these groups of people who are getting
together to make investment decisions
yeah so taos are an exciting new
structure that's emerging out of uh web
3 and blockchain technology many people
including myself have analogized dows to
being a little bit like a subreddit or a
message group that has a bank account
and the idea is a group of people are
getting together online and they want to
take it to the next level and instead of
just chatting with one another and
developing really close relationships
they want to deploy capital to purchase
nfts to invest in companies to
do a whole bunch of different things
that they are interested in doing i mean
i think that's what's kind of lost like
they're real humans that are just like
super interested in like digital art or
music or fashion they're just geeking
out on this together and you know just
trying to make an impact one example of
a tribute lapse dow and the most
successful one is called flamingo now
that is a dow that invests in nfts when
they started it cost about twenty
thousand dollars to join so you would
have about one percent of this company
or organization that was going to invest
in nfts
now it costs about eight million dollars
to join so they essentially turned about
10 million dollars into a portfolio
worth now a billion dollars so they've
done incredibly well they've bought a
bunch of crypto punks really early they
bought other pieces of art called
chromey squiggles they bought a bunch of
them for about 18 and now they're worth
about 30 000 a piece they're the most
successful
investment now today another example of
attribute labs now is neon and they
formed neon dao to focus on the
metaverse this nebulous concept of you
know everyone living in a virtual world
and what they've done so far is they've
bought some virtual lamp
and they've just been incredibly popular
all of these now but neon dao raised
about 20 million dollars in 45 minutes
when it launched
noise down which is focused on music nf
keys
they raised 7 million dollars in 30
minutes
red dao which is focused on digital
fashion raised 12 million dollars
taos are a super interesting new
emerging concept we're moving at this
point from the industrial age the
internet age endows are really poised to
be the native way that people organize
their affairs online you know that being
said it is new there are risks
there are a lot of risks a couple of the
big ones are legal risks some of these
dows that have tokens where you buy
tokens to become a member if these
tokens have certain characteristics that
the sec deems are actually investment
securities they could be in legal
trouble the people who have created the
dow and potentially participating in the
dow because if they haven't registered
as an investment security then they
could get into trouble another big risk
is scams and fraud so
there's this particular type of scan
called the rug pull where
basically people will raise a lot of
money they will form together with some
kind of goal hey let's buy a rare piece
of art or
could be anything they'll say hey
everyone let's raise money to to buy
this
and the founders of that dow could be
criminals they could be people intending
to defraud other people and once they
raise that money they could just walk
away with it it's really important for
anyone who's thinking about joining it
down to really that those people who are
leading it and organizing it make sure
you feel comfortable with them and their
their intentions
you